hi I'm mano marks I'm a developer
advocate on the Google Maps team in this
video I'm going to show you how to use
map padding to control the visible
region of your map in the Google Maps
SDK for iOS first let's take a look at
what padding does I've modified the map
padding demo in the demos project that
comes with the SDK that you can download
from the documentation page first I
disable map padding and run the demo
when I toggle the overlay it creates a
view and moves it up as you can see it
blocks a portion of the map including
the controls and the google logo and
copyright notices this reduces the
functionality of the map and is not in
compliance with the Maps API terms which
do require that the logo and copyright
notices be visible but if I Naple map
padding I can correctly set the visible
region of the map so that text and
control positioning map gestures and
camera movements all behave as if they
are placed in the padded map even though
the map takes up the entire container
the map will continue to fill the entire
container but text and control positions
map gesture and camera movements will be
hey Vaz if they've been placed on the
padded space however as you can see
through this view it retains its
original overall size the code is really
simple all you need is a UI edge inserts
object you said it using the GMs map
view padding property for more
information on map padding check out the
documentation at this link and if you
want more information on getting started
with the Google Maps SDK for iOS check
out this playlist